this Friday not only is it the best day
Jumma but also got special Black Friday
deals with nature's blend stock up now
with the 20% discount good one
one day I'm checking my messages on
Instagram and randomly I just see this
message and it's a sister who is
interested in some so this is what she
sent me and obviously at first I was
thinking okay it could be a fake account
etc so I was talking and she was saying
that she's ready to accept Islam so just
talking to a little bit I decided that
okay let's meet obviously before I did I
had to ask her to prove that it's not a
fake account so she sent a voice note
you know I could hear a voice that it's
a female okay I said okay that excuse me
so yeah we met and this is how it went
enjoy it this was an emotional story
[Music]
so honey limo feed the power
what then
don't you say yeah so yeah basically
finish out this and when you take it and
the person assist you in doing it then
read Camus yeah and but I see it as this
is a team team type of thing and also
what's very important is for you I want
you to understand that if you if you
take you Shahada that it doesn't stop
there so we like an extended family for
you you live down the road if you have
any questions because we we know how
difficult it can be sometimes at the
beginning but the most support you have
the easier it gets and you said that you
pretty much yeah research yeah that's
all same cause like when I was there
with the sister basically I thought you
know okay because I've got hot chocolate
I couldn't it might be a little
conversation and she was like no you
know you know she watches she's watched
my videos most demands a few other
bombers as well etc so and she said look
I'm I'm actually ready and I thought
okay was fun a lot of fun let's just get
the coffee and take away because and
come and see about the woods wife
insha'Allah because you know she can
help him because obviously promise you
know sister sister I can show how to
pray and I was just giving a reminder
what she's telling the sister that you
know if you think about it like I'm a
rebirth Islam though would is his wife
is an inch taller this sister's going to
accept this time now as well if you
think about it it's like a lot chooses
specific people because I love rivers if
you think about sister it's like you're
chosen to bear that flood do you get it
and you're representing it to your
family you know and a lot of people have
you said your siblings came to Islam
right yeah yeah like my mom did my
brother did your wives any family
members yeah exactly few Judy I'm
Shannon say so better in mind that Allah
has chosen you sister to be that
representative here and now along the
lines is going to be ups and downs
because Allah says in the Quran do you
not think that you're gonna say I
believe and not be tested you are going
to be tested why to see the truth for
once compared to the false ones and I
would say the best representation that
you could do and I said this to you is
well winners coming here is your
behavior you a lot your character your
man is the way you carry yourself
because a lot of the time sometimes you
know it might be hard
like that would like as that used to say
that you know and and his dad said he
was very proud of him why cuz he sought
to change the responsibility and I've
seen that in him is 100 like after he
came to Islam and you know being a
father himself but it's very important
for us to understand that because
sometimes you get caught of certain
groups and these groups can take you on
a road to destruction and what what
happiness you start despising a family
trust me and system I advise you do not
ever fall for that if you have a group
of people like oh these people are
innovators these people are disbelievers
what happens is you're gonna build this
hate because what they're doing is your
your since you're still young yeah
you're going to be thinking yourself
yeah you know I've got and you're gonna
get an imam boost and faith boost here
so when you come to Islam it's gonna be
all lovely everything is rose well you
see roses everywhere yeah but what's
gonna happen is people take advantage of
that and then what happens is that you
come home and you start despising your
family all you guys are Christian you
guys this or you guys are Buddhist or
you guys are whatever whoever and you
start being harsh to them and now
they're gonna be looking at you thinking
okay so this is the beautiful Eastham
but you've been telling us about and
they're going to judge you based on your
behavior and that's the reason why the
Prophet peace be upon him said to us he
said this and it's very profound he said
I did not come for nothing but the good
character and that is profound because
Islam should beautify one you know and
this is how man is oh you know it's very
important for you to understand that
it's going to be struggle yeah when I
came to it some I don't know about you I
got kicked out my house had to live in
mooses house for about three weeks I
lived in brought in Ron's house as well
yeah they looked after me like their own
family and it's a gradual step and one
thing that I notice with my dad
every time he would come to me and see
bin Laden on the TV and say hey look
there's your friend there and take the
mick out of me I realized that instead
of at the beginning I was oh I didn't
have the mentality of oh these guys are
nothing but I was angry because the way
he was streaming I was thinking like
what am I doing wrong I just want to
worship God and even slapped my face
once actually he actually slapped my
face my dad's not an evil person he just
has a concern you need to understand
from their perspective
Islam Isis they are thinking oh my gosh
she's gonna travel so understand their
worries just save them look it's not
like that that's not going to happen and
reassure them one thing that I realized
how it works with my family sorry for
that long leg so guys
but it's it's that um every time he will
insult me
I'll just gonna kiss him the forehead
and what I realize with that our key is
that he would just be like dumbfound cuz
you can imagine somebody swearing at you
and that slaps you in your face and you
won't kiss him in the forehead you
either gonna think he's lost his mind
or you I'm Janice day it had that effect
but anyways I want to keep it any longer
inshallah just I think you should
inshallah yeah so you'll release it so
nobody's caught you're not no you're not
held hostage here okay there's no guns
yeah we're not you know we're not giving
any kind of promises or cookies or
anything like that
yeah it's amazing why this religion it's
just about perfecting yourself and
becoming a better person yeah and being
a benefit to use surroundings if you do
these two things and you keep at it and
you put no partners inside so a lot or
like he your life is going to lead you
and you just gonna feel the happiness
that you're looking for so the religion
is based upon Revelation which is the
Quran sent down by from Allah so it's
the speech of Allah and I sent on
through big gay bro and through the
angel Gabriel I mean if you Christian
you kind of know about angel Gabriel as
well and then it is spoke to him to the
prophet muhammad sallallahoalyhiwasallam
but he's not unique in that sense
because Gabriel all the message and
revelation to all other prophets as well
yeah and so there are different books so
we believe that the Bible some parts of
the Bible are divine from our long and
the support and the Torah and we believe
in angels clearly and the last day of
judgment so there will be judgment and
we believe that there's destiny
so things are destined Goodin but good
and bad and the more you know and you
find out actually that there's certain
things you can do to kind of affect your
destiny and things like that but that's
different yeah which we accept yeah the
five pillars and these are basic in all
the six pillars of five so do you accept
you do you understand them and accept
them okay cool so the Shahadah goes
excited ashhadu an la ilaha ilallah
shadow and no muhammadan rasulullah take
care
anything visual feelings in English you
want to do oh subscribe it's a lot of
emotions up here sorry I didn't ask you
only drink something sorry we're just
excited so we just yeah so basically
what that means is that you should
submit English it means I bear witness
that there is nothing worthy of worship
except Allah and the Prophet Muhammad is
His slave and its messenger
okay so sister now what you've done is
just that imagine it that you there was
a door in front of you you've got the
keys you've opened that door this is
where your journey starts and we ask
each other for it you know beyond our
skill good deed is running short on the
day of judgment and we also got to keep
you firm and as a sister I'll give you a
romantic one inshallah that'd be very
careful in the context of and to be
honest every time I give this reminder I
feel sad that I have to but I have to
you have to be careful don't trust
anybody
yeah you would have a lot of people
Muslims you know they might be calling
something in their life and they just
want to you know take our people a
variety of other ways you know be very
careful
yeah when it comes to marriage you're
still young yeah we know you're still
young
still again you will have doubles wife
our sister here to consult anything like
that you know just make sure you consult
because there are people out there
there's good and bad in everyone yeah so
you need to be careful because what
happens is sometimes people have
innocents in them and people take
advantage and this can affect your faith
you know and believe us you can be a
witness
sometimes sadly Muslims have themselves
positives and Allah will test people
with people so these are gonna be tests
right now
allegis wants to see okay your statement
you said it he knows you know that what
you said you mean but he's going to
snuck a seal or they'll say like a gold
you know you have to purify goat and how
do you do with fire you know I want to
ask you to jump in the fire yeah the way
it's done is that Allah is gonna test
you in different ways and believe me
I've been through stuff toad knows yeah
the wood nose up and through stuff and
I've had my ups and downs and every time
I've been through something where I said
you know Allah why are you doing this to
me
well I I tell you within four to five
days what like I just click and say you
know what thank you for doing that to me
like thank God because at that moment I
was thinking why like what if I don't
know what sin have I done
but what is syste believe me Allah tests
you and he's gonna test you to purify
you and bring you step by step closer to
you believe me when I looked at myself
when I first came to Islam and you would
testify do this and our sister would as
well is that you know I was thinking
where was I what was I do not even know
what I was doing I was just all over the
place right but you see how Allah takes
you by stages and stages and purifies
you and purifies you and purifies you
till the day you die you know because he
wants you to be at that specific level
inshallah yeah and raise your ranks in
the hereafter and we ask Allah subhana
WA started to grant you Jenna
I mean inshallah on the day of judgment
sister if you do not see us in paradise
terror ask Allah you know and maybe this
little deed that we did maybe Allah
would accept it and while I were here
for you were like your family if you
have anything please feel free get the
sister's number as well anything else
you guys want to say is there anything
you want to say sister but if there's
anyone out there because you you reached
out to me on Instagram so is there any
advice that would you would give to
sisters or brothers out there who may
know Islam is the truth or they're
scared is there any advice that you can
maybe give them
exactly exactly and yeah that's it guys
inshallah so may Allah bless you guys
and we're gonna get sister in contact
with reverts realities well they're
quite good connected and that's it miele
bliss guys did if there's anyone
watching this Bravo sister and you want
to accept Islam
feel free we're not judgmental we're not
here to judge anybody we're just here to
help ensure that she got in contact with
me through Instagram or nope on sister
less me in Costa we met we came here and
hamdulillah she's accepted Islam keeping
it was a Salaam alaikum